every Thursday highlight stories
affecting consumers across the country
more than 80% of dieters are forgoing
help from nutritionists and trainers in
favor of do-it-yourself options like
diet and fitness apps according to a
market Data Report the demand for these
apps has created a growing industry of
devices and trackers designed to help
you meet your fitness goals but they can
also give anyone with access to the data
a detailed picture of your health when
Courtney Berenson wants to watch her
weight making a nutritious breakfast
includes an extra step tracking her food
with the calorie counting app my net
diary I probably could have achieved the
same goals just from keeping like a food
diary but I didn't want to I want
something that was easier than a few
ever wouldn't do it yeah exactly what is
it that makes it so easy when I first
bought it it was definitely barcode the
app includes a built-in barcode scanner
that reads and logs prepared foods now I
eat a lot more like fresh food that I
can't scan so obviously it's probably
just like habit whether you're trying to
lose it or tone it up there's an app for
that and results are promising a recent
study from Duke digital health showed
participants lost 5 pounds in 3 months
by using the popular app My Fitness Pal
Gary Bennett is the center's director we
like to say in the weight loss world if
you use more you lose more and the key
challenge for any digital health app is
how often and how long people will use
it your tracking using these tags this
will be my steps my I guess heart rate
any of those things
exactly these apps often incorporate
data from fitness trackers and other
smart devices
CNET created a wellness lab to field
test some of the new technology
executive editor Sharon Profis gave us a
tour this is the naked mirror it
actually gets you a 3d scan of your body
not only does that let you track the
physical progress of your goals but it
also gives you body mass fat mass these
gloves actually have sensors in them
they're actually tracking your throws
punch okay to make sure that you're
actually following the workout and you
track your progress over time I hit it
know it knows yeah right now a lot of
the wearables and apps are really
centered around losing weight or getting
fit but we haven't even begun to scratch
the surface on health or medically
driven needs while these apps have yet
to reach their full potential bennett
says there are already risks to consider
what's your greatest concern when it
comes to these apps and all the data
that we're putting in there whether
these data can be used to make judgments
about the kinds of treatments and
programs we have access to whether we
can get insurance how much we're charged
for insurance we can use health data to
learn a lot about a person what's
happening to the data how are they being
used how long are they being stored to
whom are they being sold those are
really important questions for consumers
to ask now when it comes to protecting
your health data gary bennett recommends
leaving out information or even changing
personal details like your age when you
use these apps but he admits even those
measures may not be enough to actually
mask your identity and you know you
think about it sometimes you're just
logging your oatmeal or your steps
that's not what you want to worry about
it's as we go down this road and how
much health data are you putting in
there and then who is able to reach that
but they work what it's showing I use
the Weight Watchers app now known as WW
and I find it keeps you accountable
exactly thing if I try to do it in my
head and think oh I'll keep track I
don't don't you have to physically put
it in you it does make you really pay
attention and that's why yeah gary
bennett said as long as you keep using
it that's the key to it so contribute
your agent I know you like that you can
be so much younger I think every wanna
be your word for it I'll stick with my
food diary